so we've got a elderly pro-life woman  who was shot in the back while  canvassing a neighborhood there was also  the case a few just a few days ago of a  republican who was run over and killed  by a guy who admits he did it because he  thought that the kid was a republican  extremist was were his words sandwiched  in between those two events we had the  FBI rolling up with 15 cars and 30  agents dragging a pro-life activist out  of his house at gunpoint despite the  fact that he committed no crimes  whatsoever they're waging all at War on  us at this point is what's happening  just a matter of like when do we decide  to pay attention and acknowledge that